good afternoon everybody thank you for
making your way out here on such a
beautiful day some quick announcements
like to acknowledge some of our sponsors
thank you as always to numb focus we're
sponsoring this Meetup as well as for a
to TD Ameritrade my employer responsible
in this space also- for sponsoring the
delicious food that we have here every
month and also to our friends our user
group in Ann Arbor for our co-hosting
this one a couple of important points
for those who are new or maybe just
forgot emergency exits there's one right
here and then there's another one that's
right outside the doors to your right so
don't take the elevators in case of any
type of emergency use the stairs always
we're looking for feedback both positive
critical negative you name it we'd love
to hear more about how we're doing as
well you can always look for some of the
slides on our github page as well
remember that we're in a borrowed space
so please do pick up pick up after
yourselves
the garbage cans are where that right
under where the food is okay so grab
your cups afterwards rules of conduct
for Q&A unless it's a quick question
please hold it until the end please
rephrase your question in the form of a
question and try to keep questions to 30
seconds or less and avoid long
statements or monologues write about how
you're doing this for your research okay
there will be time for an open
discussion at the end of sort of the Q&A
section where you can come up and talk
to the speaker or even intermingle as
well I'd like to read our code of
conduct pi data is dedicated to
providing a harassment free meeting
experience for everyone regardless of
gender sexual orientation gender
identity and expression disability
physical appearance body size race
religion or experience we do not
tolerate harassment of meeting
participants in any form all
communication should be appropriate for
professional audience including people
of many different backgrounds and levels
of experience sexual language and
imagery is not appropriate for any of
our meet of events be kind to others do
not insult or put-down other attendees
behave professionally remember that
harassment and sexist racist or
exclusionary jokes are not appropriate
for high data attendees violating these
rules may be
has to leave the meet up at the sole
discretion of the beat of organizers but
overall thank you for making this a
welcoming and friendly environment for
everybody so we like to start off with a
quick icebreaker so I'm gonna ask that
you turn to either somebody on your left
or to your right or maybe in front of
your behind you
preferably some of them you haven't met
before introduce yourselves and tell
them something that is not a
non-technical thing that you can just
talk about for 30 minutes and present
about that thing for instance talking
about how Game of Thrones for the past
few seasons are good or not right or
whatever you may be or no spoiler alert
I hear people look you'll cover their
ears right but you just tell them what
you could talk about again something
that's non-technical
all right so go ahead I don't know cuz I
thank you all right yeah yeah yeah hey
deep now young Katelyn no they see you
yeah
architecture yeah what kind of shop
[Music]
okay
[Music]
okay that's awesome
I could talk about taco places in Austin
and recommendation and pros and cons of
different types of taco he stole that
you stole this from me so I've already
used my answer poetry yeah I do yeah a
little bit not a lot it does know what
yeah
I follow
and I like really simple fun my favorite
author kind of reads like children's
[Music]
children that's great
I've heard a lot of buzz sofa you will
at least leave here and having met
somebody else that has similar interest
I'd like to stop on this one in data
science there is a new Python library
that just came out called Snuffy or
stumped by that is that could be used
for a wide variety of data might a
time-series data mining tasks I happen
to another person who created it but I'd
love for you to contribute use it
provide feedback because that person was
me and it was open source thanks my
point TD Ameritrade so you can either
check it out on our github page at TD
Ameritrade slash stumpy or you can just
do a quick install stumpy as well also a
quick plug for our event next month
Alexander Johnson from Cigna is coming
to talk to us about machine learning
infrastructure and that's back on
Wednesday June 12th at 6 p.m. so sign up
for it spots are filling up quickly just
a survey the community here if there's
any community out announcements anybody
want to looking for a job have job
openings or just have a pet project that
they want a little bit of help on feel
free to raise your hand you
what kind of work are you looking for
anybody else okay
we do video feed youth sports
I went currently hiring for a lot of
science teams or if you're interested
come fight they all do it's not that
workman and Claire was one of our
speakers for January so her video is
posted on YouTube as well to look up
Heidi to Ann Arbor look for Claire's
name and you'll at least get even a
broader idea of what her company does
other other people in the back oh me
financial
I'm Sarah analyzing on
nice analyzers just
cash
Automation
thank you
yeah my name is Priscilla and I worked
right below downstairs at llama sock we
are looking for a senior data scientist
for the machine learning team within our
company so you have anything please
reach out to three of us like keeping
your hand up so that people know who to
look for
great yes an insertion so there's
somebody on savage yes hi I'm an
undergrad studying computer science
engineering so I'm currently looking for
an internship software buffer of
position potentially at this summer
apart any project that you have I can
work on I mean anyone I would love to
help out
so and I've done three punches before as
well just like showing my interest
thank you Jane
[Applause]
yeah my name's Peter Smith probably the
oldest guy in the room here but I just
finished a Python course I love it
liquid versus something to do what a job
would be cool I've started five
companies in my life
software companies the biggest went from
basement to 150 men company I was a 3d
CAD company done a bunch of stuff anyway
I'd love for a chance to play with code
and have fun great thank you
last call anybody else great speaker
sure so yeah my name is Clayton I'm
going to organizing our user group I
gotta make sure they stand where the
camera is and I know Ellis is also here
also organizer the our user group and so
we're doing this joint meet up with high
data which is really all Shawn's work
and he's letting us take a little bit of
credit for it and so we really
appreciate that and I know I've seen a
lot of our group faces here that I don't
usually see here so thank you all for
showing up and this month we are very
excited to have Caitlyn queued on here
from Austin Texas which is Lee data
scientist at online med Edie which is a
learning platform for medical students
she's extremely involved in the
community both locally and more broadly
she's a co-organizer of the our ladies
Austin group she gives talks all over
including most recently at South by
Southwest and at the our studio
conference down in Austin earlier in
January she blogs at Caitlin
calm and she tweets from beyond a posy
hopefully she will show that at some
point I recommend you give her a follow
she talks a lot about some of the things
that she'll be covering here during her
experiences like growing a very new data
science team and sort of figuring out
what his native science look like at Anu
at a company that hasn't done it before
and I recently found myself in a very
similar position so now I'm following
her on Twitter started even more
carefully that I used to she's got a lot
of good stuff on there and it tends to
be sort of a a rallying point for good
opinions from the community because
she'll say you know what do people like
to do for this kind of tool in this kind
of workflow and and a lot of really
smart people follow her so you get all
sorts of awesome responses to see like
how do other people approach this thing
that we all deal with and so with that I
will pass it over to awesome
Thank You Clayton Gideon's hear me okay
me back yeah okay cool awesome I'm
really excited to be here so Sean
reached out to me last fall and tickle
took us a little bit to get this thing
scheduled now that I'm here one of the
things that was sort of holding us up as
I was just starting a new job so I
started a new position at the end of
September and he reached out about two
weeks into that position and we were
trying to figure out like what could I
come talk about and the thing I can come
and talk about is building data science
in an org so from the perspective of the
first data science hire in an org what
does that even mean what does that look
like what kind of decisions do you make
what is your day-to-day look like and so
this talk is just gonna be diving into
that a little bit I did put a call out
on Twitter actually to ask what kinds of
things people were interested in and I
got like five pages of responses and so
clearly this is the thing that people
want to talk about I'd love to talk to
you folks afterwards or online if you
have follow-up questions but this talk
is largely built around the questions
that came out of those conversations so
Clayton covered most of this my position
is Lee data scientist at online med ed
I'm really passionate about getting
people into data science so co-organized
our ladies Austin and some other stuff
in Austin
um I would call myself a data science
generalist have you guys heard of like
the generalist versus specialization
thing that's conversation that's
happening right now okay
so an article came out recently in HBR
and it was associated with stitch fix
and it was talking about this idea of
like a full-stack generalist versus
someone who specializes and when those
things are helpful when you have a big
team it's really helpful to have people
who specialize in certain parts of data
science like an LP or a machine learning
engineer or something like that I kind
of come at it from the opposite
direction so I've done a lot of
different data sciency things over the
past eight years or so and so I'm really
a generalist I'm comfortable working on
all of the parts of the stack but I'm
not necessarily super experienced at
every single part I think that's a good
skill to have if you're going into
startup data science and I've recently
made that transition so a couple other
things so and that's the link to my blog
at bianna Posie is where you can find me
on Twitter and other things and then I'm
hashtag building des is a hashtag I
created when I started this job to kind
of track some of the things that I was
doing and so if you go back you can see
some real-time tweets of what I was
thinking at certain times those making
decisions that sort of thing okay so a
little bit about online med ed my
employer so they are a start-up they've
been around for about four years or so
they are a medical platform that helps
med students learn medicine better so
our mission is to make better doctors
and so they have hundreds of free videos
and you can log in you create an account
you can log in and watch those videos
and they help you do better on some of
your exams if you're a med student we
also the way that we make money is we
have add-ons and we have subscriptions
that you can pay for us there are things
like notes that you can buy and download
there's like a flashcard thing that you
can do and we're launching a mobile app
very very soon and so there's a ton of
data and ways that we can generate data
around our website
and in fact they had some data before
they hired me so when they decided they
were at the point where they wanted to
hire someone they had some data already
that they'd been collecting they had
data over time but I wouldn't say that
they necessarily had data about every
part of the business that they wanted to
understand and so they had some things
that they were interested in collecting
but hadn't collected yet but they also
had piles of data that they've collected
but just nobody had done anything with
them so they had data they had business
questions they had ideas of things that
they could do with the data but they
needed someone to step in and analyze it
one thing that's really cool about this
company in particular is my boss the CEO
is a trained epidemiologist so he is an
our guy he understands our he
understands data
he gets the value of data science and
that's been really helpful for getting
buy-in and working on projects and all
of that stuff I'm happy to answer
questions about the company specifically
so when I walked in for my first day
it's kind of a green field right I
actually had done a little bit of
consulting work for them one project so
I had a little bit of a feel for what
their data was like but there was a lot
of space where I could kind of decide
what I wanted to do what projects to
work on and that's a really nice thing
as a data scientist you can decide the
projects you want to work on but it's
also sort of scary because when you walk
in you don't know exactly like what is
the first thing that you should be doing
my directions from the CEO he was about
to go out on paternity leave right when
I started and so he gave me a list of
projects that he thought would be
helpful things that he wanted to know
and then he also mentioned in that list
just add value and so I like to think of
this as part of why I'm at the company
and so I'm really there to do analysis
to do cool things to add data to their
projects to help them become more data
informed and make better data-driven
decisions but I'm also like bottom line
there to just add value so when I see
things the data could help improve or
processes that I think we could work on
I have the flexibility to be able to
kind of step in and help with just been
really useful so I'm going to talk a lot
about data infrastructure and when I say
infrastructure I do mean all of the
things here but I have another slide to
show you the other side of
infrastructure that I mean so when you
walk into a company and they might have
data collection mechanisms that's how
they're getting their data how are they
capturing it so for us we were capturing
whether people watched videos for
example because you could mark that
you'd watched a video we also were
capturing individual things that you
could do on the site because there are
certain parts of the site that you had
to be a paid user in order to access and
so we have to gate access and so there's
some data there which was great when you
start working on problems you'll quickly
discover what the data pipelines are if
there are any data pipelines so does the
data go from the mechanism into a sequel
database or something like that or is
there a more complicated process that's
moving data around or combining data
from different sources you start to sort
of see that right away and then the
databases in warehouses themselves what
do those look like are there many
databases is there one database has it
changed a lot over time are there core
tables that you need to care about and
you'll discover that very quickly as
well as any tools that they have for
doing exploratory data analysis analysis
in general or machine learning tools and
so that would probably be if a company
was a little bit more advanced but I
think this is all this stuff that we
think of when we think of infrastructure
when we talk about data architecture
there's a lot more that goes into doing
data science effectively and efficiently
though and so I'm calling that
foundational infrastructure different
people have different terms for it
but one huge piece of that is
documentation and knowledge capture and
so making sure that the data you're
tracking like the lineage or tracking
any institutional knowledge that you
gained around that data
this is actually a really nice project
when you're first starting because
you're learning a company's data while
you're learning their business and their
tech stack I tend to take notes about
anything that I'm learning and so taking
those notes and turning them into
documentation is a logical next step and
it helps me as much as it helps the next
person also policies politics
communications so if you exist within an
organization you have to talk with other
people you have to communicate and
politics can become a part of that that
doesn't necessarily mean it's a bad
thing it just means figuring out sort of
how you're going to communicate with
others also establishing policies around
your data so if there are certain ways
that you want to treat certain pieces of
data maybe there's some data that
everyone should have access to maybe
there are some pieces of data that you
don't necessarily want to use for
analysis starting to establish those
things on the team creating a plan to
deliver on goals so eventually you're
going to create goals or things that you
want to do and you need to have some
sort of plan of how you're going to get
from raw data to deliverables for the
company whatever those deliverables
might be so infrastructure isn't just
coming in and looking at the pipeline or
the sequel database and doing things
from there it's a lot more packaging
around it and then also as you start to
build a team thinking really carefully
about the structure and the roles on
that team so different teams look
differently depending on both the size
of the org that you're at as well as the
function of the team so in some
companies data is really the core
product those teams tend to look very
different than if you're working at
something like a start-up where they're
starting to add data or access the data
that they have and do analysis around it
so a little bit about what my first week
looked like this is not very data
science II but I think it's useful just
to get everyone on the same page like
the first week looks like the same week
at a lot of other jobs so learning the
business model is really important if
you've seen the data science been die
knowing the business is a big piece of
that getting access to all of the things
that you need access to database that
takes time that takes communication
talking to different stakeholders so my
boss had me meet with the two lead
engineers in my first week so I kind of
talked about where things were if they
had plans that might work with the data
we wanted to know that I'm starting to
learn the data itself and its lineage so
I started to dive into the databases a
little bit just a little bit of like
select star from limit five what does
the state I'll even look like what does
it tie to or they're things I could tie
together and starting to get the stories
like the oral history of some of the
data so when I came in my boss said you
know I'd love to hand you a map but
startup and so I really learned that you
know sometimes as much as people would
like to document things and would like
to have this perfect documentation you
know time gets in the way and so getting
comfortable with that and talking and
starting to write things down as a way
to add value very quickly another thing
that I ran into was a little bit more
cultural so I was the first data
scientists that anyone in my company had
worked with and that was a really new
position for me as well I've done data
science for a number of years and a
number of different orgs but usually
there was someone who was sort of
familiar with data science my CEO was
familiar with data science because he
sort of came from that world like
epidemiology statistics he got it so I
spent a lot of time my first week just
kind of explaining the things that I did
and some of the questions I got were
really basic even things like do use get
and so we really had to do a little bit
of Education around the types of things
that we were doing with our data
currently the types of things that we
wanted to do with the data what the road
map was and just talking to people and
getting them on the same page with what
my role was what my tech stack was it
was interesting I got to know all of the
people who spoke Python very quickly so
yeah
another thing that's really important I
think when you're starting any new job
but particularly if you're building
something if you're building towards
something I read this book the first 90
days based on a recommendation on
Twitter and so your early wins have to
be kind of double wins like you want to
be delivering value as soon as you can
for the company but you also want to be
laying out the infrastructure and
building things out so that things are
better in the long run and so that was
something that I kept in my head a lot
when I was working on some of the early
analyses so I'd spend part of my time
doing analysis and then part of my time
building towards the future that's a
really tricky balance I would love to
hear other people talk about how they've
done that but yeah just being cognizant
of the fact that you want to be
delivering things while you're setting
up for the long term
have you guys ever seen the data science
hierarchy of needs is this familiar some
of you okay cool
I love this this has been so useful for
explaining in my org what it is that I
do and why I care so much about
collecting data and having good data and
vetting it so at the very top of the
pyramid we have AI and deep learning
that's the stuff that they've all heard
about right below that a be testing a
simple ml that kind of stuff that stuff
that we can get to pretty easily and
even if you walk into a startup that has
some data you might be able to get there
fairly quickly but I think it's really
important that the collect moves store
and explore transform all come at the
bottom of the pyramid like you really
need to have good data good data
collection in order to do all of the
cool stuff at the top of the pyramid and
so my first six months really have been
focused on the bottom of the pyramid
making sure that we have data we have
good data it's going to the right places
that sort of thing but yeah giving this
as a visual for folks to understand it's
been really helpful as I'm trying to
like build a case for building some of
this stuff
so in the first few weeks I built some
core tooling and I have this it's a
no-brainer thing over here because these
are the things I would do if I were to
walk on to any team
these aren't decisions that I had to
make that were specific to being the
first data scientists are working at a
start-up these are just things that I
would do if they didn't exist in any org
so this is general advice one is stack
tools I'll show you in the next slide
what I mean by that but getting things
set up with like a git repository
setting up a slack channel just setting
up all the things that your team needs
to communicate and share work also
building a data dictionary and so shared
language of what your data means and
we'll cover all of this a little bit
more in depth a query library so
tracking all of your queries and get if
you're querying something often it's
probably very important probably
something you want to track and then
creating some sand block sand boxes to
connect to the data and start playing
with the data analyzing the data and a
little bit of templates for building out
projects so Stack tools and some things
I added in the first few weeks
this is confluence so we use the atlast
act that's something I didn't make a
decision about it's a really common
stack but that confluence is like a
place where you can gather knowledge and
so it's kind of like wiki documents so
we have our data science space and we
have some pages and stuff that I've
added there we added a JIRA board and so
we could talk we could do a whole
separate talk about running agile on
data science and whether that's a good
idea or not a good idea I have some
opinions but I'm still tracking the work
that I'm doing in tickets so we created
a JIRA board so that we could start
tracking the work a data science channel
on our slack internal slack group
channel and so this was partially so
that we could answer questions from
other people in the Oregon then
partially so that I could disseminate
any of the things that I've done and
then finally we use bitbucket instead of
github but repositories so creating
places where we could put and store our
code and give everyone access so these
are just kind of the basic tools that I
think you would need to set up a team
I'm sure there are more things that you
could add to this list but this is what
I did in the first few days first week
that I was on the next thing that I
worked on is building a data dictionary
so as I was talking with people from
different teams about the types of data
that they had what data pain points
there were there are fields or tables
that they were using over and over again
I was recording all of that I think
that's really important it's really
helpful for yourself so you're setting
yourself up to answer questions in the
future but also for the next person so
the next person who started working with
the data I gave her a data dictionary
and so she has the things that I have
explored my knowledge of those things I
have worked at places where the history
of the data is entirely oral that's a
really bad thing that's not a thing that
you want to start with and so I think
when you're learning is the best time to
really be building these things the
other thing that's kind of cool about a
data dictionary is like it tracks my
knowledge of the data as I'm building it
and we'll see the same thing with a
query repository but you can see me
learning the databases and the data
better by like the updates in the data
dictionary and query libraries which is
kind of cool because your analysis is
only as good as your knowledge of the
data and that really is going to inform
the conclusions that you make so when I
say a query repository or oh you have a
question
yeah so nothing that was built to make
data dictionaries mine's just in Google
sheets and so we have a shared Google
sheet and we have the Lincoln that we
put the link on our confluence
eventually it should have a better home
but for now start up and we're still
building it so yeah good question and
also different people have different
opinions on that this is actually that's
a question I asked on Twitter and I got
a lot of really interesting varied
responses that would be a good thread
for me to probably go dig up but if you
search for it I'm sure you could find it
people have strong opinions on the tools
that you should use to do that and where
it should live some people think it
should live within your like sequel
queries or within your code I opted to
keep it separately and that's just
worked for me on other teams but you
could really go either way yeah those
are small decisions to make depending on
that work so the query library is just
the idea of taking your sequel putting
it in a place where other people can see
it and then tracking it with git so if
you're changing your sequel over time
for me for example I'm finding out more
about our user base a lot of this stuff
that involves is like filters like as
you figure out like oh this field made
sense at this time but then this thing
happened in our software and it changed
and so maybe don't use it after this
time if you start to look at someone's
sequel queries over time you'll see that
sort of change and this is really nice
because you can document like why you're
making those changes and what the
knowledge was that caused you to update
those queries and you're always going to
need that query again that's my other
thing whenever I do like a one-off
project someone always asks for a
different version of it or an update of
it and so it's really nice to just say
the sequel one place and have access to
it another thing that I've done is
sandbox projects with notebooks how many
of you have ever heard of project
template before it's an r package or
cookie cutter for Python okay yeah
it's the idea of creating a template for
your projects and it just makes your
life a lot easier you don't have to
think about the architecture the
scaffolding you just kind of copy this
pre-existing thing and then you start to
fill it in with like your notebook and
your data and all that good stuff
so this is the outline that comes with
project template I didn't actually use
that this time around I learned by using
project template I've edited a little
bit but I think they're a good starting
point and then the other thing is like a
sandbox notebook and so I couldn't
actually paste our notebooks here but I
kind of pasted the idea of what they do
importing a bunch of commonly used
packages connecting to the database I
put like a sample query in there and
then taking that query and turning it
into a data frame and so that's just a
really nice thing because then I can
edit it and I get started and I just
don't think about the scaffolding
anything that saves me time and that I'm
doing over and over again I try to
automate and earlier the better so that
was the first week two weeks or so
so the first six months really like what
I've been doing up until now a lot of it
has been tooling decisions and making
decisions about the business in this
talk I'm not really going into much on
the analysis that I was doing but I was
balancing this the whole time with
delivering analyses and answering
business questions so that's kind of the
piece that's missing from this picture
so one of the questions that we had was
like how can we help with business
intelligence we wanted to make some bi
sort of decisions and by b.i I mean in
this case I guess like data that was
looking backwards at what happened and
so we have stakeholders who want to be
able to answer really basic questions
things like how many people used our
software in the last month and we didn't
have anyone doing that and so I built
some really basic reporting and stuff to
do that are we collecting enough data so
we knew that there were holes in our
customer acquisition flow in our usage
that we wanted to try to plug and so we
had to figure out the best way to
collect more data sharing our analyses
so originally when I started doing
analyses I would put them in a report
and then I put that report on confluence
because that's where we wanted
everything to live in one like central
location but pretty quickly I realized
that's not reproducible that's not best
practice I was going in and just
updating the numbers on the report like
once a month and so we decided that we
needed a tool to be able to share these
things and to be able to help other
people like run them live that would be
helpful and so we started looking into
different ways that we could share
analysis a lot of these are problems
that I've encountered at other companies
but usually at the point at which
someone has figured it out and so the
thing that was most interesting to me is
like the decision-making process around
this like I know I need reproducible
reporting but what do I actually do to
get there helping other departments so
we know there are departments who are
not data-driven who haven't seen the
data that goes along with their work and
so we wanted to be able to provide that
data and help them make good decisions
shaping data pipelines so I think this
is actually a good project to do at a
time where you've been working with the
data a little bit not right off the bat
because you know the data better you
start to know some of the quirks you
start to know some of the things that
you might look out for and so I've
recently started thinking about data
pipelines and what those should look
like and then what other resources do we
need so as we're going along or
realizing there's other resources that
we need what are those things how do we
get them so we'll walk through some of
these decisions this first one was
around powering business intelligence I
don't know if you've all seen this
before it's a tool called chart mogul
and so one of the things I had to do is
the first data person in the org was
connect the data to all of these
different apps and things that would
help the business so this is a bi tool
this cohort analysis is actually kind of
cool it looks into the way that people
turn over time but powering this thing
actually took some time and some
thoughts so we have changed our billing
system twice and so those migrations
I mean that we have data lives in
different formats and different systems
from different times and so that's
something that I had to think about how
do we combine those things and actually
we have an engineer who does a lot of
customer support stuff and so she had a
really good understanding of the data
and the billing systems in particular
and so she was particularly well suited
to help with this project and connecting
accounts across systems and that sort of
thing that's not a really that's an
example of something that's not super
exciting it's not an exciting or new
problem to solve but it's the kind of
thing that needs to get solved and
preferably the earlier the better so
that those things aren't pain points
later on down the road another thing we
had to focus on was data collection and
so my friend is an analytics architect I
didn't know that there was a term for
that role but what she does is worry
about eventing data and figuring out
what that data should look like and how
it should interact with different
systems and so I've spent probably four
months working on our data architecture
and our data collection that's really
like that's the bottom part of the
pyramid it's super foundational super
important and so we settled on a tool
called segments that decision was made
before I came on board but it's been
good so far and we used that in order to
collect data on our website so for
example if you do a search we weren't
capturing like what folks were searching
for there's business value in that we
could start to do predictive things
around search we could start to upsell
and cross-sell there's all kinds of good
business things we can do there so one
of the things that we had to do was come
up with the kinds of events that we
would want to track how exactly we would
want to track them where we want that
data to live how does that data combine
and someone has to be sort of in charge
of all of that and so that's been a huge
part of my role is personally coming up
with like over 200 events that we're now
tracking on our website and then working
with our devs to implement the tech that
we need in order to track those
things queuing that data which is super
important so the things that I'm asking
for from our devs are not always exactly
the things that I get back things get
lost in translation and communication
and so it's not just coming up with the
plan it's also working through the data
and making sure that it's actually the
thing that we think it is and that it's
doing the things that we think it is the
other kind of cool thing about segments
is that we use it to power some of our
other data outputs and so we've
collected that and Amazon redshift
it feeds Google Analytics we're able to
connect it with HubSpot which is a
marketing tool talk about that in a
second and then we're able to connect
that with mode analytics which we're
using to do analytics and dashboards so
I'm sharing analyses internally this is
where we're using a tool called mode
analytics there's all kinds of stuff
that you can use to do this you can also
choose to like spin up your own way of
sharing reports so this decision took a
lot of input from outside sources I
talked to friends I asked questions on
Twitter and eventually we decided to
give this a try partially because of our
particular needs so our data lives in
multiple databases and it was
surprisingly hard to find a tool that
lets you combine data from multiple
databases and then let business users
kind of access that data that's one of
those pain points that's very particular
to our organization but when you start
looking at tools those are the kinds of
things that you have to think through so
we're able to share analyses internally
here and it allows you to build like
Python notebooks and our notebooks so
you can do an actual analysis it's not
just like select star from and then
bubble up that report which has been
really nice another thing that we've
done is enabled marketing with data and
so this is HubSpot those modalities are
things that people can do on our website
like you could download a whiteboard
it's like an image of after a lecture
all of the notes on a whiteboard those
are things that we're collect
with segments and so those are things we
had to specifically decide that we
wanted to collect decide that we want to
analyze down the line invest in that
value and then pull that in as the only
data person making sure that the right
data goes to the right person in the
right way that has fallen to me and so
this is an example of the kind of
project that I'm doing if I'm helping to
enable other stakeholders and it's all
this sort of foundational work that'll
let us get even more data and have even
more things that we can start to analyze
which is really exciting
shaping data pipelines so focusing on
pain points we figured out that in order
to see purchases at a certain time we
have to query and go through a kind of
stake through something like eight
different sequel tables those things
just weren't designed by a data
scientist or someone with the end data
or the end use of data science in mind
and so having someone like me go back
through them and kind of figure out like
okay where could we pull this data how
could we pull this data together in a
better way in our own pipeline where we
could build our own sort of curated
version of the truth that makes sense
for doing analysis raw data is artifacts
it doesn't necessarily represent the
truth it represents the truth at the
time at which you pulled it and in the
way in which you pulled it and so
sometimes you have to kind of navigate
what that truth might be and pull the
data into a different format to make it
work for you or to make it work for the
team the third piece is automating where
it makes sense so as I've been finding
pain points like oh hey I pull this same
query once a week at least that tells me
that that should be its own view or its
own table I should be doing that rollup
once so that I don't have to keep doing
it so the analyses that you're doing can
start to inform the architecture and the
data engineering decisions that you make
another really important part is
knowledge documentation so these are
actual tables that we have in our
confluence that help to explain
different parts of the business and it's
mostly the stuff that you like have to
go look up you're like oh what was that
Koh
what did that mean or what was this
group of people and so I would advocate
for taking anything that you constantly
have to look up or try to keep in your
head and just writing that down putting
it in a central location letting
everyone see it and edit it and touch it
and then you get the shared benefit of
the knowledge across the institution so
for example we have different
subscription codes so we created this
thing that explains all of the different
subscriptions and and what they mean
from a business perspective another
thing that's been really useful here and
in other companies is like a calendar of
notable events so sometimes you'll be
looking at data over time and you'll see
like a weird spike or a weird dip or
something that's unexpected and when you
talk to a business stakeholder you might
develop a whole analysis and then talk
to a business stakeholder and they'll
know something like oh yeah that's when
we switched billing systems or that's
when we launched that new product or
that's when so-and-so is started working
on this other stack and so those kinds
of things are so helpful to know in
hindsight when you're looking at the
data but they're not the kinds of things
that people think to write down
especially if they don't come from a
data background so we've created a
calendar of those kinds of events and
you can see some of the questions that
we're answering and then also promotion
codes overview so we have like
promotions that we offer in our store if
we're doing cohort analysis some of the
people who buy on a promotion might look
different than customers who don't buy
on a promotion and so knowing that data
and understanding it having some having
it summarized in an easy way just makes
us get from raw data to insight that
much faster so the data science
hierarchy of needs if we come back here
and this is really where I've spent my
first six months so a lot of collecting
the data a lot of moving it around a
little bit figuring out storage figuring
out what our event should look like and
designing that stuff this is all stuff
that is investment right so we're
spending a little bit of time now in
hopes that it will pay off in the long
run having a really solid data
infrastructure
is something that we'll be able to
optimize both for our team as well as to
leverage on other teams
so as we're finding pain points and
creating new resources to tackle them
we're creating things that are useful
for other people a good example of that
is like switching billing systems in
order to find all of the people who have
ever made a purchase for example that
means that you have to go to different
billing systems and so one of the things
that we've created recently is just a
single table with all of that
information sounds so simple but if you
don't have that you're constantly just
redoing this work and rethinking through
things and it's just clogging up the
amount of time that it takes to get from
data to actual insight so the next six
months and will be spent just a little
bit further up the pyramid so the
collect stage is nearly done moving and
storage is kind of the next thing that
I'm going to be really working on
alongside some analysis so we're
actually going to get to some cool
analysis in the next six months that I'm
really excited about
so this role has been a little bit
different than like a traditional data
scientist role because you're making
some of these decisions that are
foundational and you're setting up both
yourselves and other people to be able
to use the data in a way that's
effective that's been really cool and
interesting for me especially as someone
who has opinions about this stuff having
seen some of the way that people work
with data been cluttered by poor
ecosystems this is a problem I've been
really excited to work on but I feel
like it's really important to be honest
that if you get hired as the first data
scientist in a company you're not
starting out doing AI unless someone has
curated a really beautiful path to get
there for you so sometimes I sort of
feel like I'm the person writing out in
front of the army to see what everything
looks like and sort of come up with a
plan and have an idea before we actually
get people and invest time and resources
into all of that stuff
so some upcoming projects for me
building stronger data pipelines so an
engineer once told me that startups run
on cron jobs and duct tape and I love
that it took me a while to kind of wrap
my head around the idea of that being
okay because I came from larger
companies where that's not something
that they would encourage but yeah for
now we're crown jobs in duct tape and
we'll get to a point where we'll need to
have something that's a little bit less
brittle and so I'm excited to work on
that a little bit alongside the analysis
also enabling stakeholders with data so
we have a ton of different ways like all
of this new data that we've been
collecting with that tool segment those
two hundred-plus events that's data
that's never been seen in our company
before there's all kinds of value there
that's completely untapped so I'm really
excited to share that and do more
analysis on all of this stuff I got a
few questions about like first data
science projects and what to pick in my
case my CEO understands data he had some
questions that he knew were the types of
questions that I could answer but I
think general advice is like to talk to
stakeholders figure out what's working
and what's not and if there are pain
points if there are things that they
kind of wish they could see and where
data could be the most helpful I've
actually been having those conversations
last week this week and next week and so
these are the questions that I'm asking
my stakeholder so if you want to steal
these you completely can but I'm asking
basically like what data do you wish you
had like in a dream world
what would you be collecting and the
sooner I know these things the sooner we
can set up for them so even if we're not
collecting it now in six months we might
have enough data to make some really
cool decisions and do some interesting
analysis what data you use currently and
where does it live I'm just interested
in this from a data perspective so if
folks are grabbing data from a source
that you didn't know about or maybe a
source that isn't as up-to-date as
another source it's really helpful to
have an idea of how data flows around
your organization and I don't mean in
pipelines I mean like where do people go
when they have these kind
the questions and then my last question
for the stakeholders is like do you have
any questions about data and online
meded and that's been really interesting
there are people who have had like
legitimate questions about things that
we're tracking or where do things live
or how do I access and so it's been nice
to get some of those pain points out of
the way so that we can help like
democratize our data and get more and be
able to provide more the other thing so
like build versus buy and vendor
decisions is something that I've been
asked about I think this is really tough
it's really org tie org and decision by
decision but this is the way that I
think through it so I think the most
important thing you can do is develop a
really thorough understanding of the
pain points of your organization and how
you might fix them then go ahead and
survey the landscape see what kinds of
solutions are out there talk to your
developers to if you're thinking about
building something in-house like what
would that look like what's the effort
I've been surprised sometimes at how
easy or hard things would be to track if
we're interested in tracking them build
versus buy so talking to people has been
really helpful and then asking for
advice so I specifically asked the
community when I have questions but just
asking for advice generally has been
really good and then weighing out the
pros and cons of short-term versus
long-term solutions so you might notice
that we didn't go with tableau as our bi
tool I've worked in organizations where
tableau has been really great it's been
really helpful we don't need all of
those bells and whistles right now it's
just not where we are and so just being
realistic about the pros and cons and
short term long term where are you now
where do you want to grow it's been
helpful question yeah it should be yeah
exactly totally yes of course
budgets a big consideration so like for
us you know we're a startup we have to
make tough decisions and we have to run
in a way that's a little bit agile and a
little bit like edge of the map and so
that can be a really cool thing it can
empower you to look at new tools or
solutions that other people haven't
tried
but it also can mean sometimes that
things can be cost prohibitive some of
the common tools and then finally make a
decision and you can always go back if
your decision doesn't work out you know
but just getting something in place and
then another question I've been asked a
lot about is being the only person it
who is doing the thing that you're doing
in an org and like what do you do and
the thing that I do the most is lean on
community so and the community has been
really helpful for answering questions
that I have I shared this slide because
when I was trying to figure out like
okay how do other people distribute or
host reports and dashboards like I have
some ideas I've done it in other
companies but like maybe there's
something out there I'm totally not
considering and you can see I got 51
responses so people are really
interested in sharing their knowledge
and sharing the things that they've
learned and taking some of that advice
to heart can be really helpful you can
also keep you engaged with other people
so it's nice to have an idea of what
other people are doing and then you can
take those best practices in-house as
well as have a sounding board so you
don't feel lonely or like you're really
the only person doing this stuff there
are lots of people who are the only data
scientists or the first data scientists
are a new data scientist or a very
experienced data scientist wherever you
might be
[Applause]
oh my your advice or your Indians differ
in giving data people that are in a
large organization
is there anything about what you're
saying that's different requesters
yeah repeat the question sure so how
would my advice change for someone at a
large organization so I think if you're
at a large organization and you're
making your first data hire and there
has truly been no one focusing on the
data you're going to run into a lot of
the same problems that a startup or a
small organization would and in my
experience large organizations are made
up of smaller organizations so even when
I've been in a large org the databases
that we're using might be specific to a
group or a smaller part of the org and
so I think a lot of this will translate
some of the budget stuff won't
necessarily I'm really lucky in that I I
can make decisions you know I have I've
been empowered to make decisions and of
course like I talked them over with
other people but I've found that in
larger organizations sometimes there's
just more parts of the ladder the chain
that you have to work with and so there
can be a little bit more political
maneuvering that you need to do or sort
of justifying things and that can take
time and you might make some decisions a
little bit differently
you might not pick the most cutting-edge
tool if you have to prove to your boss
that it's absolutely going to work and
going to solve all your problems
question is what would trigger the hire
the person like you sorry yeah so um
online method I believe is around 40
people right now we've done some hiring
lately so it'll settle somewhere around
there and then what would trigger the
hire of someone like me I think when you
start to have data and you start to have
business questions you start thinking
about like okay I don't have time to
analyze this who can analyze these
things and if you find that there's no
one in your org who has the time or the
capacity to answer the questions that
you have then it might be time to bring
someone on another thing I didn't really
cover here but it's also really
interesting to have a data scientist
work in the architecture of the data
collection that's not a thing I've
always gotten to be a part of it's been
really cool from my perspective because
I've worked usually at the other end of
that River
like the data has already been collected
and flowing but to get to have some say
about that has been really interesting
and so it's worth considering what kind
of person you might bring into that role
a data engineer might make sense for
some folks but a data scientist or
someone with an analysis background I
think can bring a really interesting
viewpoint to that conversation
okay so the question is I came to online
met at a startup as someone who had
experience in data science and would it
be easy for someone who doesn't have as
much experience to work in a start-up or
as the first data science hire I would
not advise if you are coming if it's
your first job to be the first data
science person I like to learn from
other people I think it's really helpful
to see things done right and even
sometimes to see things done not so
right in order to build up some of the
intuitions in order to make decisions
that will have long ranging effect that
said I think becoming a generalist is a
really useful skill knowing just
something about each part of the process
makes you communicate better with people
in a larger org and so I would
definitely encourage people to go work
at a startup
I just wouldn't encourage you to be the
first hire
the first fire that doesn't yet have
this
how do you convince the operation people
of you
that are why entire you was worth it in
the long term
once were here
yeah I think being upfront with that
idea when you're in the interview
process I read a really good article and
it was called like how not to hire your
first data scientist and it was about
this really terrible situation that can
happen we're like you expect great
things from this person they come in and
they're like there's no pipeline and so
they're like okay I need devs to build a
pipeline and then folks are building a
pipeline for you and you're not doing
anything with the data and that leads to
frustration and it's it's just a really
tough situation I think communication
would be the best way to kind of cut
through that but that's a that's a tough
situation and it's also about like
managing expectations I'm really lucky
like my CEO understands data understands
that this stuff takes time but I could
see marketing marketing makes things a
little bit tough right it makes it seem
like it's really easy to walk in and do
that stuff and that's just not always
the case
that's because here and then
okay sure my biggest frustration is just
how long things take I want I want to be
done collecting data like I want to have
that and I want to build pipelines and I
want to do all of this cool stuff and
it's just everything takes longer than
expected it's like if you're sizing
tasks for like agile or JIRA you're
always supposed to add you know a
certain amount of time so I think my
biggest frustrations are with timeline
and just getting things done
there's a science project that might
interest you
sure so I went to school first
statistics and I double majored in
statistics in English and my plan was to
go actuarial so to do sort of data
science II things in the insurance
industry while I was studying for
actuarial exams there was a company
nearby that was hiring and it was a
predictive analytics company and so that
sounded really interesting to me
predictive analytics was my favorite
part of learning stats not necessarily
something I thought was a job that you
could do full-time and so I interviewed
with the company they hired me and I was
absolutely hooked on predicting things
and so my first job there I stayed there
for about four years and that involved
some consulting work it involved working
with really messy data non profit data
if anyone's ever gotten into that so it
was it was really good but my first
projects were building models for
nonprofits yeah so with that I'd like to
thank you in again for a wonderful talk
thank you sure but also specifically I'm
Emily for sharing her journey but also
for for myself right for being an
example especially in terms of
soliciting advice from the data science
community because it is a new thing
right and I think it you're setting a
wonderful example for all of us here of
how to approach that so let's thank you
have a great job
[Applause]